graph the inequality Y minus 4x is less
than negative 3 so the first thing we
could do is we could kind of put this in
MX plus B form or slope-intercept form
but as an inequality so let's start with
we're starting with y minus 4x is less
than negative 3 we can add 4x to both
sides of this inequality so let's add 4x
to both sides of this inequality and
then we'll just have a Y on the left
hand side these guys cancel out see if Y
is less than 4x minus 3 we could have
negative 3 plus 4x but we want to write
the 4x first just because that's a form
that we're more familiar with so it's
less than 4x minus 3 and now we can we
can attempt to graph it but before I
graph it I want to do something a little
bit gonna be a little bit careful here
so let me draw our axes so this is the
x-axis and this is that is the y-axis
and we want to be careful because this
says y is less than 4x minus 3 not less
than or equal to 4x minus 3 or not Y is
equal to 4x minus 3 so what we want to
do is kind of create a boundary at Y is
equal to 4x minus 3 and the inequality
the solution to this inequality will be
all of the area below that all the Y
values less than that so let's try to do
it so the boundary line the boundary
line would look like let me write over
here so we have a boundary we have a
boundary at Y is equal to 4x minus 3
notice this isn't part of the solution
this isn't less than or equal it's just
less than but this will at least help us
draw essentially the boundary so we can
do it two ways if you know slope and
y-intercept you know that 4 is our slope
and that negative 3 is our y-intercept
or you can literally just take two
points and that'll help you define a
line here so you could say well when X
you could say when X is equal to 0 what
is y you get 4 times 0 minus 3 you get Y
is equal to negative 3 and we knew that
because it was the y intercept so you
have 0 and then you have 1 2
zero and negative three and then you
have the point and then you have the
point let's say when X is equal to I
don't know let's say when X is equal to
2 when X is equal to 2 what is y we have
4 times 2 is 8 minus 3y is then going to
be equal to 5 so you go 1 2 then you go
1 2 3 4 5 and so you have that point
there as well and then we can just and
then we can just connect the dots or you
could say look there's a slope of 4 so
every time we move over one
every time we move it 1 in the
x-direction we move up 4 in the
y-direction so you could draw it like
that but so the line will look something
like this and I'm just gonna draw it a
dotted line because remember this isn't
this isn't part of the solution actually
let me draw it a little bit neater cuz
that point should be right about there
this point should be right about there
and then this boundary line I'm going to
draw as a dotted line so it's going to
look like it's going to look something
something like that I draw it a dotted
line to show that it's not part of the
solution
our solution is the Y is less than that
so for any X so you put pick an X here
if you took 4 X minus 3 you're going to
end up on the line but we don't want the
Y's that are equal to that line we want
for that particular X the Y's that are
less than the line so it's going to be
all of this area over here where less
than the line and we're not including
the line and that's why I put a dotted
line here you can also try values out
you can say well there's two this line
is dividing our coordinate axes into
essentially the region above it and the
region below it and you can test it out
let's take something that's above it
let's take the point 0 0 let's take the
point 0 0 and see if that satisfies our
inequality if we have Y is 0 is less
than 0-3 or we'd get 0 is less than
negative 3 this is definitely not the
case this is not true this is not true
and it makes sense because that 0 that 0
0 is not part of the solution now we
could go on the other side on the other
side of our boundary
and we could take the point I don't know
let's take the point 3 comma 0 so let's
say that this is the point well that
that's right there's a point 2 comma 0
let's take the point 3 comma 0 right
over here this should work because it's
in the region less than but let's verify
it for ourselves so we have Y y is 0 0
is less than 4 times 3 minus 3 0 is less
than 12 minus 3 0 is less than 9 which
is definitely true so that point does
satisfy the inequality so in general you
want to kind of look at this as an equal
to draw the boundary line we did it but
we drew it as a dotted line because we
don't want to include it because this is
it less than or equal to it's just less
than and then our solution to the
inequality will be the region below it
all the Y's less than the line 4x minus
3